here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show ALS panel is it time to
repeal the death penalty
yeah I think is a concern for me is a
conservative if I support life I
shouldn't support it kind of across the
board and I think that's been a real
[Applause]
yeah I mean I like it in principle I
just think that there's there's so many
times they don't get the right lawyer
you don't know but it when somebody I'm
sure like they they brought they're
gonna bring the death penalty against
the tsarnaev
I'm all for killing him yeah I don't
have a problem with that I think you
just sort of leave him alone in a room
with no food or water and a pistol in
one bullet that way you can't reach
other the humane way but you made one
person that death is not guilty we are
murdering people and we shouldn't do
that yes okay
how could charm oak rats trust that you
won't one day switch back to being a
Republican great question once you go
back great question no listen if you've
seen what I've seen in the leadership of
the Republican Party I don't want to
paint too broad a brush but it is a
party that you know we talked about
earlier where even Jeb Bush says that it
is perceived as anti-women anti-mine or
'ti anti-immigrant anti-education
anti-environment I mean pretty soon
there's nobody left in the room and
you're backing away from the party just
because this stuff is true what kind of
lawyers only that I first of all I mean
it's a fun question but I don't think
that's it never happened is there any
precedent for someone actually going
back to a party I doubt it I don't think
so I don't think of one example of
someone went oh [ __ ] what did I do you
know I really should still be endeavor
to make a decision like that is not an
easy thing to do and it really isn't I
mean it's much easier to just conform
and try to you know make it work out but
for me like I said earlier the way mom
and dad raised my three sisters and me
there's no way I could do that and look
myself in the mirror and be honest with
my core values
right and what I believe okay Tom as
someone involved someone involved in
combating hunger what do you think about
President Obama signing the farm bill
today oh yes I thought it did sign
almost a trillion dollars over ten years
yeah I think I must be fair it really
should be called the Food Stamp bill
because most of it is well it it most of
it is food and that's a fact and most
and most of the food is produced by
farms okay but that's a misleading
I think now listen it's a terrible bill
and I'll tell you why for a few reasons
one it cuts eight point nine billion
dollar from food stamps but but the real
giveaway here's to the insurance
companies one point four billion dollars
a year let me explain this how it works
it sounds like it sounds like a nice
thing insurance for crops but that's not
what this is it doesn't guarantee your
crops it guarantees your income and so
your guarantee eighty five percent of
your income okay that's that's okay
but 62 percent of the premiums are paid
by the government okay seven point eight
billion dollars of deductibles are paid
by the government I'm just saying the
facts of this the bill is nine hundred
and fifty six million dollars seven
fifty six is to food Stan so it really
is the Food Stamp bill two hundred
billion goes to farmers over ten years
it's called nutrition over twenty
billion dollars a year we're giving you
a we should not be giving farmers money
to do what they do anyway especially
when pot no you can't separate this you
can't separate the bills is that why the
too early no it was originally it was
really linked together to to balance the
needs of urban areas with rural areas
because also the needs of and it's not
political because you had the needs of
hunger or usually in urban areas but now
would spread out across the country so
it's changed but also it's dulled unless
you know since 2007 because of the
recession that's gonna drop
automatically on its own when the
economy starts to rebound in fact it's
leveled off already and so it's it's
it's not the Food Stamp bill it's the
nutrition so let me go it's coupled
because liberals in the city Democrats
and welfare programs and vice versa I
mean or as part of this bill is the farm
part of this
and I'm thinking that if it weren't
attached with liberal support to the
Food Stamp bill we can get rid of the
farm half or farms and a half but I'm in
the farm section very hard in America to
ever get rid of any program once it
starts way too strong too well the
grotesque part of the bill is on the
pork
it is larded with pork that has
absolutely nothing to do with farms or
with food stamps
a hundred million to move maple syrup
seven set twenty million dollars for a
new catfish office yeah Edna Street tax
and earmark about 70% 70% of the Tea
Party caucus voted for this bill Oh
pox on both their houses believe me I
asked a Democrat and a Republican member
of Congress on crossfire how could
either of you vote for this it makes no
sense to me and I think it's a real
insult to the American people who said
how could you the bill cut about 16
billion dollars and more than half or
half of that between 16 is twenty three
billion half of that came from poor
people so why so you have eight hundred
and fifty thousand households okay Jimmy
Kay asked the panel if you could get
President Obama to pass one executive
action what would it be
he's stone pipeline and politically that
would hurt a lot of Democrats in red
states oh and that's what we want that's
what he's about why it's gonna happen
does he want the Senate does he want to
keep the Senate that's you should want I
would say carbon tax that's what I would
love if I could but that's the exchange
if you're gonna sign if you're inside
Excel get something for it right for it
learn how to work trade a little bit you
could
what are you doing immigration do is he
can halt deportations of non because I
think he already did that was this big
but already know what daca which the
young was the DREAM Act yes anybody
meant about yeah immigration who isn't a
Cherokee or sue if a Cherokee or sue
says why doesn't this country have the
original ethnic makeup that it always
had
[Applause]
[Music]
they got a point okay that's an amazing
point if I might
yes immigration it's the fact that the
Congress can't get its act together
enough to acknowledge that we are the
melting pot of the planet and do
something right to move forward on this
issue is shocking what are you a lot of
things on my father's side Greek and
Lebanese and on my mother's side
Irish Swiss and a little bit of Welsh
the people mispronounce your name when
you're a kid Christ Christ Christ sakes
get over funny I committed to go to to
Israel first and so I went to Tel Aviv
in Jerusalem and it's a true story
Robert Wexler was with me you may
remember former member of Congress and a
great guy and the Jerusalem Post writes
Christ returns to Jerusalem SE Cupp
would you agree that it isn't
conservatives and that most americans
have a problem with but the majority of
Republicans who appear to care more
about their lobbyists and money
I think that's uninspiring on both sides
of the aisle to any constituent who's
unhappy with their congressman or their
senator and they think that they're
working for other people instead of for
them I don't think that's just a problem
on the right it's a problem but like for
example when I read that the first thing
I thought of was most Americans are for
weight raising the minimum wage and I
can't think of any reason why
Republicans are against that except that
they are in the pocket of big business
who are the only ones who don't want to
raise the minimum there's plenty of our
economic economic arguments against
raising the minimum wage but really you
raise the minimum wage you raise the
cost of labor there's less labor
he says otherwise yeah it hasn't been
disposed no I mean 100% true well this
is one of the problems yeah one of the
problems with the right weight is that
one can zip is that when they get
information they don't take it into
account I saw Bill O'Reilly with the
president and he asked him questions
this is of an hour before the Super Bowl
and he just asked him you know questions
about things that have already been
vetted over and over again how come the
IRS guy came to the White House 158
times well you know they found out why
why it's like information comes in but
it doesn't really sink in but have you
watched or followed where he's just done
an ode to Bill oh yeah we every show
about his own interview with the
president know it's gonna go down in the
annals of broadcast history that's what
he said today like it brings people on
to analyze this interview you think how
good did I do
[Laughter]
all right we gotta go thank you very
much everybody
Real Time with Bill Maher ask filling
his guests your questions right after
the show
at hbo.com or on Twitter